Chinese president Xi Jinping met with
his Russian counterpart during a state
visit to Moscow
and is soon expected to talk to
Ukrainian president valada mazelenski
for the first time since the war started
while the West has expressed concerns
over China's deepening ties with Russia
Beijing has indicated an ambition to
help bring about talks toward a
ceasefire in Ukraine Xi Jinping one of
his main goals is to to make China into
a superpower and so part of that is
being involved in security discussions
and peace talks around the world recent
diplomatic breakthroughs brokered by
China offered tangible evidence that
Beijing is willing to use its influence
to help resolve foreign disputes
Austin Ramsey covers China's Global
reach for the journal and explains what
beijing's model of a new diplomacy means
for the U.S
on March 10th Iran and Saudi Arabia
announced that they agreed to
re-establish diplomatic relations after
seven years of estrangement in a deal
mediated by China
House
this is a sort of thing that would be
difficult for the us to bring about the
U.S doesn't have formal ties with Iran
and is of course very critical of
Iranian authorities there was obviously
a concern that the U.S had lost clout
particularly in the Middle East and
China was now playing this much more
important role
and this wasn't the first Showcase of
xi's diplomatic ambitions
last June China offered to quote silence
the guns across the troubled Horn of
Africa at its first Regional peace
conference
delegates from six countries gathered in
Ethiopia to hear China's pledge that
Beijing was best placed to restore
stability to the region the Chinese
approach to these negotiations can be
very different from from the United
States China has a policy of
non-interference which often means not
being critical of governments and just
focusing on bringing them together that
can be very appealing especially to to
governments that don't want their
records examined while China has sought
to contrast its Regional policy with the
US Washington has accused Beijing of
using the mediation dialogues to bolster
authoritarian regimes and expand its
security footprint
an analyst say securing any diplomatic
wins in Ukraine would be a much tougher
challenge for Beijing European capitals
and Washington have so far greeted
beijing's diplomatic push with
skepticism China can't have it both ways
when it comes to um when it comes to the
Russian aggression in Ukraine it can't
be putting forward peace proposals on
the one hand while actually
feeding the Flames of the fire that
Russia has started with the other hand
both Xi Jinping and Vladimir Putin share
a deep distrust of the U.S and the west
and they see the world order as led by
the West to the detriment of their own
countries and so it's very harmful for
China if Russia is damaged by the war
and it no longer can can play a role in
in supporting this effort to sort of
lessen American and Western influence
over the world as part of its push for
what he calls big Power diplomacy
Beijing increased its budget for
diplomatic travel and other related
expenses by 12 this year
in a bid to counter China's inroads it's
very very good feedback in Africa
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
traveled to Ethiopia and Niger in
mid-march
and he's just one of the many U.S
officials who are visiting regions where
Washington and Beijing are competing for
influence I think nothing focuses the US
like a competitor this could um sort of
bring about a sort of renewed American
efforts to engage in diplomacy around
the world engage in diplomacy in some
places that the US might have might have
ignored a little bit in recent years